Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News
you're watching swipe on the show this
group prepare for the apocalypse we head
to the theater with a bunch of zombies
DIY drones the 3d printed gadget
designed for kids and we ride the
highway to hell in this week gained
review hello and welcome to swipe this
week with zombies because we're on the
set of an immersive theater experience
going to see a show isn't just about
relaxing into your seat this one is
interactive
not all immersive theater is this freaky
but it is supposed to feel very real
the aim is to make you the audience feel
like you're in the story part of the
adventure and this adventure involves a
zombie invasion what up front of grown
siderably we need to move at the huge
East London set of the generation of Zed
apocalypse the audience gets split into
groups and taken on separate journeys
some of the rooms are linked up by
radios and CCTV so you can see what's
happening to other audience members
making it feel a bit like you're inside
a video game even if one of the
characters you're in a different room
too you can see them throughout the show
because the the technology is is linking
them through the through these four
rooms that are filled with with cameras
and screens I think the while the show
is has lots of freud's and it's
terrifying at the same time it's not a
scare ride and we do want the audience
to be invested in the characters and
really care about them if something
something awful happens to them people
died yet although blurring the lines
between actors and the audience can have
its drawbacks for the cast I've been
attacked by audiences members who felt
they had to defend themselves I've we've
had a woman lose control of her bladder
we've had a teenage boy get overwhelmed
and vomit on the floor because the scene
was too gratuitous for him hmm this is
probably a good time to bring in
something less terrifying those going to
see shelter me another interactive
performance in London described as a
digital circus experience are asked to
keep their phones on so they can receive
text messages and calls as part of the
show
but there's some debate over whether the
term immersive theater is becoming
overused and that some of the technology
can be a distraction really you're
getting away from what is theater which
is something that is live that's what's
unique about it and if you are just
over-reliant on video screens or
projections or wizzy tech or using your
phone or Skype or whatever then
sometimes that can seem like it's just
there to be a bit clever rather than to
actually really add anything to the
theatrical experience you will fall
asleep fiction which is based around a
collective dream puts its audience in
pitch black for an hour with headphones
that play 3d sounds which make it feel
like the sounds are in the room with you
although not every theater go it takes
fully to such experiences there's been a
few shows where and the lights come up
at the end and the audience members who
have curled up in a fetal position but
on the whole people do enjoy the
experience I think the audience
appreciate that if they leave then it
will be a real pain for everyone else in
the room so trapped that sounds terrible
it's great fun and everyone enjoys it so
we're still on the set of generation of
Zen you can hear there are some scenes
going on right now we can go behind the
scene this is a control room think the
producer charlie mcdermott Charlie talk
us through the kind of tech trickery
that's going on in here hi so welcome to
the control room so what we've got going
on here is 12 different cameras we've
got a mixture of pre-recorded footage
and live recorded footage so what we've
got are the live rooms here that are
going on now one of the characters has
had to go to the gate because her
daughter's turned up but in a moment she
trips a trip wire which explodes the
gate and we use pre-recorded camera
trickery to show the illusion of
hundreds of zombies pouring into the
facility then live we have live sounder
pics and live actors banging on the
walls so the audience jeans when we
wonder that
that was the explosion so the gate has
pulled out now the zombies are pouring
into the facility whilst the audience
are freaking out screaming loads of
zombies the audience think about what
they're actually no they think their
beer but they're not so on the screens
they can see them coming in they hear
the sounds and completely by that there
are hundreds of zombies in this compound
does this sometimes feel like a social
experiment it really does we have
choices in the show that affect the
narrative and it would be amazing if I
could tell you the percentage of people
who genuinely believe that the zombie
apocalypse could happen we we've
surveyed about 5,000 people and seventy
percent of them believe that yes this
thing could really happen it's
phenomenal the Ortiz white still to come
we're off to the dungeon in our games
with you but first here's a bite sized
chunk of this week's tech news Apple's
British designer sir Jonathan Ive has
been promoted the man who masterminded
products such as the iPhone and Apple
watch is now chief design officer he was
previously senior vice president of
design he'll still be an overall control
of how Apple's products look but another
Brit Richard howarth has taken over as
head of industrial design periscope has
finally arrived on Android up until
tuesday you could only get Twitter's
live streaming app on iOS devices it's
been a big hit with celebrities and the
media including us at Sky News this
footage was broadcast by our Asia
correspondent Mark Stone following the
earthquake in Nepal earlier this month a
company in the US has developed a drone
designed to be put together by kids the
3d printed sky BOTS can be modified by
its young pilots and programmed to make
it do what they want early models on
Kickstarter cost around 40 pounds nearly
half the world's population will be
using the internet by the end of this
year according to the International
Telecommunication Union 3.2 billion
people will be online about 2 billion of
those will be in the developing world
now the games in our review this week
aren't quite as scary as this place but
one of them is based in hell so don't
relax just yet here come with the
details so there are lots of fantastic
games that you can play on your phone
and on your tablet
or free and that's what I want to talk
about in this week's games review so the
first one is hell writer so in this game
you play as a guy a skeleton actually on
a motorcycle inhale and then it's quite
a simple game you just touch the change
direction and you're almost slaloming
your way through this map trying to
avoid obstacles triangle to run into the
lava so it looks great it sounds great
and it's fantastic game if you're stuck
on the tube or on the bus and you're
just trying to you know get your
destination but also progress and beat
your high score so a great free game
their home or platforms another free
game I got my hands on and actually
wound up spending a lot of time playing
his little game called quest keeper and
this game you play this little block e
guy so it's cubes this time not
triangles and you swipe to change the
direction that you're traversing through
this dungeon so again it's one of these
games where you know you die frequently
and then you have to restart but it's a
bit of a slower pace and it's got lots
of role-playing game type of elements in
it so you know you collect little items
and bits of clothing to increase your
characters can I skills and stuff as you
go along but it's just really nicely
made again the art style is really quite
adorable and it's a great game again to
just trying to progress and beat that
high score and a wonderful time going
now hearthstone is a very different game
in the previous two I've talked about
it's not one of these flappy bird type
games where you dialogue it's a card
game so the way it works is you'll play
against another opponent you'll both
have a deck of cards and as you play
cards you get little creatures on the
board and their goal is to deplete the
health of your opponent sounds simple
but actually it's incredibly complicated
because you can build your own decks to
have different strategies maybe you want
to attack really quickly maybe you want
to be defensive maybe you want to use
lots of spells but it makes for a really
competitive experience one downside is
is quite a time investment and it is
quite addictive
hearthstone heroes of Warcraft well
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can stay up to date with all the
latest tech news on Sky News iPad or
smartphone apps Coney's calm and our
YouTube channel I'll see you again next
week oh I just need to find the way out
Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News